Hello bitches.
[inaudible] get it Puerto Rican beard.
Yeah,
I mean we could do a five hour podcasts and just keep drinking.
I don't mind.
It's up to you dude.
But what's about,
uh,
two 15.
What time did we start this pitch?
1130.
Yeah,
we get it dirty barbers minutes.
I got a little tweezer thing or a little clipboard right there.
You ready to do this shit,
Tommy?
Hold on Tommy.
Tommy's just decided this is happening.
No hold show.
Are you going to go with,
is a bunch of attachments to that Jammy?
Depending on how close and if you want a sculptor or contour or anything along
those lines,
but are you going to try and do the prints you think Tommy?
Um,
here's what I want to do.
I want to,
I want to bring all this out.
Bring that bottom out.
Okay.
Right,
right.
I'm put a nice line.
Yeah.
And then,
okay,
you're going to sculpt it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This is going to be a pro job.
Okay.
What about the stash?
That's what I was saying.
I want to bring,
yes.
Oh,
what is this?
Oh my God.
I might have to be this,
but if he did that,
he's just going to shave that off.
Hold on a show that it looks so good.
Oh my God.
Oh,
these fucking pictures.
A dude's beards.
It's so ridiculous.
There's nothing better than the Jaguar guy though.
The Leopard Guy.
Pretty guys off the charts.
I gotta put this on my phone too,
because I don't want to show my daughter and hold it.
Hold on.
No,
no,
no.
Hold on.
I'll just wide angle so I can move over there.
Okay.
I'm gonna move over here.
She guys with a beard is my on it.
Total gut health and
oh shit.
Oh really?
I put it,
I should put it in like a a ramp.
Want me to hold it?
No,
I'll give it left this out.
Uh,
be happy.
I want you to be a part of it.
I don't want you to know I'm right here though.
I know,
but I don't want you to have to focus on me on you're holding it and give me
that fucking thing.
Shut up.
I'm right here.
I'm just going to rest it right here.
Drive.
Am I getting Harrell in me right now?
Tom,
you're going to get a little bit of hair on you.
Hold on.
Let's,
let's tighten this up.
Oh,
you got your passwords,
Hun?
Oh,
it's a four,
four,
eight,
seven,
seven.
All right.
Good luck finding my phone.
Wow.
He's just now on it became a challenge.
Just like the weight loss challenge.
Syphilis.
Hold on,
hold on.
Fuck with my hair.
Like my actually hair.
Hold on.
No,
no,
no.
Give me a landscape in which
landscape landscape.
Flip it this way and now I'm going to have to do the fucking anything on this.
Okay.
Hit stop record and I hit record.
Okay,
we're recording right now.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm putting this here.
I'm going to take a Bert Kreischer.
Please explain to the people it's about to happen and why
my beard is getting shaved because I challenged Tommy bonds on a beer challenge
on who lost was most weight and he lost a collective like six pounds more than
me.
I failed.
Go ahead.
But you did succeed in losing a ton of weight.
I lost.
I lost 35 pounds I think so I,
I,
I'm happy that at least I'm not as fat as I am.
Just start.
What if you look better before we do this?
I will not better.
What if you decide like,
I like the new Burke.
Maybe the new,
it's new bird doesn't,
doesn't right
Taj things.
Maybe the new birth,
but this new film already uncomfortable with this.
Can we go?
So Tommy Burns insisted in shaving a beautiful pattern.
I've worked so hard on that area.
You worked on.
What did you do?
I just grew it out and I sculpted it
all sculpted area vulnerability.
How's it scope?
But what I do is I,
I went to a black barbershop and I told them that,
that people might cut my beard.
He taught them,
I asked him,
ask them,
where's the microphone on these things.
I might've had my fucking finger over the microphone on your cell phone is okay.
I hope I don't.
No,
I don't.
I'll fill you on the podcast then to be going really hard.
No,
no.
It looked good.
So you're sculpting you.
You're not entirely shaving it off.
Tommy,
talking to the microphone please.
Soap Bar Tommy.
Why we decided to go high.
That's one of the yard as Amy Jo Jawline.
Tommy,
why have you decided sculpted and not completely shave it off?
I see this is a guy where like I see so much potential and I just want it.
I want it to maximize like,
oh,
where are you going to work?
Your phone is exploding with text messages.
While I'm holding this up,
I could barely look at it because the screen keeps fill it up with
he's giving you a Hitler son.
Oh my God,
this is so stupid.
What's wrong with us?
We're all adults.
What the fuck is wrong with us?
Oh my God.
Can I please see it?
God.
Oh my God.
So you're doing the prince.
Oh my God,
I can't breathe.
Oh,
cool.
Huh?
Is this the first time you save another man?
Oh yeah,
but I've thought about it a lot.
I still feel the same right now.
Jimmy,
what about Costco?
What are we doing?
You can't drink right down,
son.
You're in labor.
You given birth to the new bird.
Oh,
this is hilarious.
Tommy,
you an artist,
you know he used to do Tommy.
What's that?
Once a year
offering this sculpt a fan's beard.
You're a God damn artists dude.
Good job.
It looks amazing.
Really?
He should be the new thing that people do.
Go back to like sculpting beards.
That could be a show
that could be show he sees as all the fluid I have on my body.
This could be a show you do on the travel channel where a y'all get fucked up
and you get someone and you shave their beard.
He barrier right there.
Oh Shit.
Wait Til your voice.
Don't go too hard on high
vulnerability.
Oh,
you look really good.
Accurate.
Really?
Yeah.
For Real.
You're going to like this.
This,
this.
This might be the greatest,
greatest time I've ever had been applied.
We guys were pretty clinic yet.
All right,
so for people just listening,
what Tom has done is sculpt birds,
beard in what could best be described as a fencer for the 16 hundreds in France.
Offense her.
Yeah.
He looked like he do that or a,
or someone who would lie about being Puerto Rican cause they're really from like
somewhere that no one's ever heard of and they're tired of people saying,
where the fuck is that?
And they go,
it's,
yeah,
I'm just Puerto Rican.
Have a look.
He looks very Spanish Mike.
But New York city fly.
You might stick with it.
You,
you might.
Oh,
Brill.
He's a goddamn artists.
Imagine if it turns out the Tommy Buns is the premiere beard artists in North
America.
I mean,
people are watching this and wants to,
the way really,
how many people are watching this?
4,000.
That's so ridiculous.
I feel like you might really be happy with it.
Okay.
Where are you going to keep this or are you going to turn to me please?
Huh?
That's actually not bad and I'm not bullshitting.
I'm not bullshitting at all.
I don't want to be surprised.
Let me see.
I'm not bullshitting you.
Look good dog.
This field.
Here's the thing,
man.
Look at your,
I looked like I work at blue.
The apes.
I look at it.
No,
no,
this is not
Joe t doesn't good.
Look at all the hair on me.
You get an earring on each year.
A big hoop,
but I look like,
I feel like you rent the jetskis for sure,
but the heat through like what are you good idea
to fucking Jane Hula Hoop earrings.
Take your phone
buddy.
Oh my God.
It looks pretty good.
Yeah.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
Look,
can you see yourself performing like that?
Fuck yeah.
Yeah,
of course.
You have to for a while,
right?
What?
I'm going to shave it off tonight.
No,
no,
no.
You should definitely go on stage for the audience.
The people that are going to appreciate,
they want to see you knowing exactly what happened.
That's the second book.
He's got to fix it.
It's not done.
You know?
That's what weird.
We never really determined when he's done so Tom can make step back,
look at it and decide to do some changes.
Oh my God,
he found the rash.
Yeah,
man.
Sometimes we have rashes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's not your fault.
I know you feel like you did something naughty,
that the Lord punished you with a rash,
but that's just superstitious
crashes.
In fact,
a really bacterial infections on the surface of your skin feels so weird.
It's definitely better now are I recommend defense soap.
I'm say I say just a mustache.
Fuck all that squirrely little bottom here.
If you want to make them keep it for a while.
Yeah,
I'll keep it for a while.
I'm a grown man.
I'll go.
Let me shave my mustache.
Okay,
how about this?
We get rid of all this crazy shit.
Now I know what it looks like.
Give you a goddamn police things mustache,
man.
You actually look like I look like a monkey for real.
Let me see you.
You looked like he looked like a top notch bowler from Wisconsin.
Here dude is on like world series of bowling and everybody fears you like the
Bill Murray character.
Can you imagine making out with me in the dark and you're like,
what does that on the top it would be covered in the beard.
What was that movie?
Fucking break kingpin.
Was that movie?
Good source.
Flirt with a girl and he goes,
not you.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh Man.
Remember when,
uh,
we had to have sex with his landlord and order to pay for the rent.
Nothing like that to loosen up,
but shit,
throw it up into the toilet.
You remember that?
He,
um,
he has the planned like robbery with the guy and then,
uh,
sorry,
my face in it.
Then he,
uh,
he throws hot coffee in that guy's face because he has to act like that.
It wasn't a scam.
You know,
like,
like the landlord comes and he's like,
what?
You're here and you just takes the hot coffee and splashing in the guy fucking
screens for his life.
Jesus Christ.
This feels so weird,
Huh?
This looks so,
I can only imagine.
It feels weird.
So I didn't know my face will be this close to my bones.
Well do do you guys view,
just don't do it like this,
like this craziness,
but just keep going healthy style,
you know?
I mean we've got to figure out a way to get you guys to not,
I mean,
let's be honest,
if you're not,
there's no way to do it.
Like if you,
if you,
if there is a target weight,
you're going to dehydrate yourself,
right?
Yeah,
of course you're going to,
you never know.
Very seldom does someone go,
I'll get below that.
You Post that picture of me,
the dog to me right now we're going to get totally used to it,
but I do suggest you keep the mustache.
I think it's a wonderful accoutrement to your face.
Okay.
It helps you party man image and again you'll kill your curling champion from
Saskatchewan.
It looks like a duck hunting guide is a totally different person.
So wild to do head shots while
you live at a guy who teaches people how to fly fish.
The guy that knows the difference in a Mallard duck.
Exactly.
Less a diver duck.
Totally different kind of meat.
You look how you definitely don't live in your hometown
and you got to Pennzoil Tattoo.
I like this bond a mustache.
How's it look good?
He looks really good.
Really?
Yeah.
You should see it closer.
Let me see your Instagram.
I do think there's something to be said for bringing back a mustache.
There's a few people who do it and it's a strong look.
No,
it looks good.
It looks like they're look stuff up there.
Oh,
uh Oh.
I need to get my teeth cleaned.
Jesus.
This just looks sad.
No.
Oh,
it looks actually,
I guess it looks like a guy who lost a fuck ton of weight,
just not to win a competition.
A mustache.
You rock this look and you go back up to two 56
that would be a,
that would be an interesting.